معنى الان نشيد
الى بالي في اندونيسيا اهلا بك نجيب نتوقف
معك بعد هذه اللقاءات التي جرت بين الرئيس
الامريكي
والرئيس الصيني وكذلك بين الرئيس الصيني
والرئيس الفرنسي اضافه الى اجتماعه اخرى
نتوقف معك عند مستجدات الوضع حيث انت
اجماع على ضروري تجنب التصعيد في اوكرانيا
الجانب الصيني ايضا يعني اكد اهميه عدم
الاقتراب من موضوع من حافه الاشتباك
النووي ولكن لا يزال الغرب بانتظار يعني
موقف صيني اكثر حزما ربما لن ياتي من بكين
وربما ستكون يعني همم سيكون التحسن في
العلاقه الغربيه الصينيه في اعلى السعيد
على الاقتصاديه فقط حيث هناك يعني رغبه
واضحه من الجميع باعاده التعاون الاقتصادي
والتجاوز همم يعني اثار وتداعيات ازمه
الجائحه الفيروسيه على الاقتصاد العالمي
والصين ايضا بادره للمره الاولى يعني همم
بعض التراخي اتجاهها الاجراءات الحازمه
جدا التي كانت قد اغلقت الصين بالكامل همم
يعني بسبب التفشي الفيروسي همم هناك ايضا
كان يعني همم
ال الحده من الجانب البريطاني حيث يعني
ااا قال دعا رئيس الوزراء الباطن
البريطاني هناك همم وزير الخارجيه الروسي
لابروف الى همم دعاه دعاسه من خلاله الى
ايقافه هجومها البربري على اوكرانيا كان
هذا التصعيد يعني لم يكن همم كان
استثنائيا في هذه القمه حيث كان هناك عاده
يعني ابتعاد عن التصعيد ولكن هناك الشعور
بعزله روسيات طبعا يعني تتجسد في عدم حضور
الرئيس الروسي ولكن هناك ايضا شعور ان
المجتمع الدولي ما عدا روسيا يتوجه الى
تشكيل يعني خلف دولي وان يكون ايضا واحده
لتجاوز تداعيات ال- الازمه الاقتصاديه على
الصعيد الاقتصاديه همم الاجتماع الذي حصل
امس بين الرئيسين الامريكي والصيني كان له
همم اثر كبير على اسواق الماليه في الصين
وفي الدول الاسيويه المحيطه المؤشرات في
هونغ كونكر بنسبه تجاوزت اربعه بالمئه
وهناك النظره ايجابيه بشكل عام الى
التطورات الاقتصاديه التي سوف تتمخض عنها
هذه القمه
شهد النشيد الى هذا اللقاء الذي جرى بين
الرئيس الامريكيون نظيره الصيني كانت هناك
اجواء ايجابيه بعد هذا اللقاء لكن ربما
ذلك يعود الى تفادي الملفات الخلافيه هلا
ربابه من اجراءات همم ملموسه يعني صدرت
بعضا اللقاء بين الرجل
من الصين اللي رفع بعض
الاجراءات التي تشمل حظرا تاما هي في في
فتره الحاليه حول دخول الى جانب الى الصين
بدات تشعر انه لابد لها ان تعود الى
المجتمع الدولي اقتصاديا خصوصا اننا نرى
ان هذه القمه التي هي تعقد في جنوب شرق
اسيا جنوب شرق اسيا الان بعد ان كانت لي
سنوات
الاستثمارات الصينيه والغربيه واليابانيه
وغيرها اصبحت ترى نفسها الان بمثابه بديل
المحتمل عن الصين هناك شركات عديده
امريكيه يابانيه وغيرها تتجه الى نقل
المصانعها من الصين الى الدول المجاوره
فالتساؤل الان هو هل ستعود الصين الى
سابقه عهدها وهل سيتوقف هذا هذه الهجره
الاقتصاديه من الصين الى الدول
اندونيسيا شكرا